peu
[Musique]
fest'of que tu représentes loto pour toi
pour voir l'otan c'est tout je veux
continuer à chanter pour m'acheter des
voitures ce que je vois c'est d'avoir
une auto qui va très vite pouvoir aller
très très vite que tu as appris à
conduire tout seul oui tu as commencé
tout de suite par une ferrari
non j'ai commencé j'ai une petite austin
aussi des petits couples et festif c'est
ma seizième voiture c'est parce que tu
en as cassé beaucoup
moi j'avais cassé 5 puisque ses cinq
voitures par exemple une ferrari ça
représente combien de l'escip long du
trajet pas fait le compte
je préfère un compteur de vitesse
trois cent mille disques quand je
conduis je pense à rien je pense qu'à
mon retour je pense à mon frein au
débrayage ou vitesse j'écoute le bruit
c'est une musique en face ça m'apporte
quelque chose j'ai besoin j'ai besoin de
mettre le pied dans un accélérateur
parce que c'est parce que j'aime ça
j'aime voir mon aiguille de son j'ai pas
de sens avec 249 150 sont respectivement
dans ta vie quelle est l'importance
respective des filles de la chanson et
de l'auto ton classement bon classement
j'ose pas dire parce que si 10 loto dira
oui mais s'il ya pas de chance on n'y a
pas d'autorité va voir alors je dis
chansons mais c'est quand même auto
avant moi les filles c'est bien aussi
combien de voitures actuelles
actuellement actuellement un g4 nature
j'ai une ferrari une shelby une ford
mustang l'élastique presse qu'est ce que
tu préfères conduit
la ferrari et la cooper s parce que de
conduite tout à fait différente c'est
mon passe temps favori qui
collectionnent les timbres
moi je collectionne des petites autos
d'ailleurs je réponds aimerait partir
avec du départ avec les autres comme ça
c'est le rêve
c'est un super rêve mais j'aimerais
j'ai fait sa musique la soie rouge avait
bu
un peu trop le whisky
aussi vous valiez
avec ma guitare
je cherchais mes mots et meriem pour
faire ma chanson
[Musique]
j'ai fait cette musique un soir où
j'avais dû entrer sur les jeux
en cognant partout quant à mes paroles
je peux vous le dire vous allez rire
vrai et ça devenait cela
[Musique]
une galette ce matin
ouais
quittant qu'il fallait
je
[Musique]
ce gars 53
hier
[Musique]
en temps
cette musique
[Musique]
je n'ai pas su trouver
devant
et cette chanson
quand je les trouve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette chanson
[Musique]
cette arme
comment comment
canon
[Musique]